and i'm reluctant to say this because i
really like anthony lynn it's starting
to feel like it's going to be over for
him and this is an opportunity for the
chargers to upgrade sometimes you have a
coach
or or what name the job whatever the job
is
it can take an organization to a certain
point and then it peters out and you've
got to make the tough decision if we
want to get to the next level
we need to we we need to go in a
different direction and i feel like the
chargers
whether they make the decision or not i
feel like they're at the point where
maybe they should and again i don't like
saying that because i have a lot of
respect for anthony lynn there's too
many close games
and what we've seen two years after
there were a lot of close games that
they won and got to 12 and four too many
close games that they just keep losing
and losing and losing and losing and
he's the guy who's become the focal
point whether it's clock management
you know special teams are decisions
like running the ball after connecting
on a hail mary that gets you inside the
five and saying
those are the things that are just going
to get you fired no questions asked yeah
i mean there's no doubt you're right i
mean there's you know between the clock
management issues throughout the year
you know the third phase of the game and
special teams always being below average
and you know they they you know moved
their special teams coach last year to
make him a senior assistant you know so
that tells you there and hey this is the
other thing because i really like
anthony lynn too but just what's scary
just as a guy who's sitting here
watching football
you know
when you have the number 12 ranked
defense in football and the number four
ranked offense in football
and what are they right now three and
what are they now three and eight
there's somewhere issue as far as
managing a game
managing situations and not doing well
you have the four offense
and the 12 defense you should not be
three and eight and that tells you
there's issues somewhere there about
what they're playing in situational
football and i think that kind of
explains it all
situations for the bills from time to
time call for a trick play brian dabal
the offensive coordinator not afraid to
use them i talked to allen about the
trick play we saw yesterday it involved
cole beasley
in the backfield motioning left turning
around running to the right allen
throwing a lateral to beasley and then
beasley connecting for a touchdown with
gabriel davis and they call the play
wolf pack because they stole it from nc
state i found the play it was from 2016.
jalen samuels the
steele running back was the was the one
who made the throw and it's it it was
exactly the same play it's but this is a
testament to coaches they're always
looking for anything that they think
they can use and they're holding it
until the right moment against the right
look against the right team and they
think it's going gonna work and it
worked and alan told me i had one job
just make sure it's a lateral yeah it's
not a lateral you can't throw it again
and that was the one thing he was trying
to do and he's not bothered or at least
he says he's not bothered and i have no
reason to doubt him i think he's very
authentic and he'll tell you how he
feels yeah you know sometimes
quarterbacks get miffed when the ball
gets taken out of their hands if you're
a franchise quarterback the rule of
thumb is you never take the ball out of
their hands but uh they use those trick
plays it seems like once every few weeks
right and if you use them at the right
time the key is time and you use at the
right time it's gonna work and uh credit
to brian dayball they make it work yeah
he does yeah they're they're not scared
to give their team the advantage that
way you know and you're right they break
them out all the time it's part of their
offense and i'm sure josh allen he likes
it takes a little pressure off him every
now he gets to be the recipient of one
of those passes and score his own
touchdown but it just makes them more
dangerous as a football team and dave
ball with that you know new england
background too i mean they've always
been the league leaders in trick plays
and doing things like that so i think
that adds to you know his uh what you
know
just his boldness as far as calling
those plays and when to call and man
mike i don't know the bills
you know
the yesterday's win was impressive in in
some ways i know it's the chargers and
they're three and eight but the chargers
defense we just talked about it's pretty
damn good offense is pretty damn good
they move the football and the bills you
know this is a game where we saw them
win a game
and it wasn't about their offense i
think that's encouraging it really is oh
that man they ran the ball a little bit
we saw the defense play well and make
some stops you know it was tough
sledding on that chargers offense all
day long and that's where i give the
bills like a little bit of that i know
they're a playoff team
but because of the mcdermott and day
ball factor and i think when you get to
play off football and their ability to
game plan and break teams down and do
things you know outside the box that's
where if they can get their defense to
continue to play well and run the ball
just a little bit and enough they could
be dangerous to where all of a sudden
we're shocked you know we're shocked
whoa are the bills in the afc
championship game something like that
it wouldn't surprise me i think with
that coaching staff and some of the
talent they got on the team
they had to wait two full weeks to play
another game after the hail murray
they're now 1-0 post tail murray while
the cardinals are 0-2 and the bill's
overall
eight and three there was a moment
yesterday where josh allen got twisted
up
and he thought that a heart attack was
injured and it seemed like he was a
little bit
affected by it he said it hurt he
definitely felt it didn't feel good but
it's going to take more than that to
knock me off the field it's easy to say
when you're young and and and things
don't break they just bend a little bit
and he's probably going to be feeling it
today but one of the benefits of of
having that youth that allows the the
the ligaments to bounce back quickly and
not maybe get injured the way they would
10 years from now
assuming josh allen is still playing and
no reason to think he won't be
the bill's eight and three the browns
eight and three yeah and
i got jarvis landry on the phone
yesterday he had a great day eight
catches 143 yards and a touchdown
and you know they win the games they're
supposed to win
and they've won enough games now
they're guaranteed their first
non-losing season since
2007 when they were 10-6 but missed the
playoffs when derek anderson spent most
of the year at quarterback
for for cleveland
i asked landry do you guys you know
because yeah you know you're not
supposed to peek ahead you're not
supposed to think about anything other
than what's right in front of you it's
all one day at a time you hear that all
the time from guys like bill belichick
and it works for the patriots so you
assume everyone does it
i said do you guys talk playoffs he said
all the time we talk about we talk about
playoffs all the time and and they're
they're already like trying to
to spot in their own games things that
went right things that went wrong things
that could cause them to lose they're
watching other games and they're
studying situations and they're trying
to learn everything they can so they're
going to be ready when those big moments
come around and the next two weeks some
big moments come around because they got
the titans
and they got the ravens yeah and they
have to show that they can win a game
that they're not supposed to win and
this is their chance the next two weeks
even though the ravens are sliding into
that territory of maybe this is a game
the browns are supposed to win the
browns lost to the ravens out of the
gates 38-6
so it's gonna feel like a game that the
browns are supposed to lose no matter
what happens to the ravens this week
against the steelers and next week
against the cowboys it's gonna feel like
this is a game that the browns maybe
shouldn't win maybe that's the game
where they convince themselves and
everyone else that they really are here
uh and a force to be reckoned with yeah
you're i mean i i know what you're
saying with the browns you're right it's
like hey they're eight and three we like
a lot of what they're doing how good is
that eight and three i'm just not quite
sure yet yeah it's been a favorable
schedule and like you've said
you know
other than the cults
they're one in three against like what i
would call good teams in the nfl right
that's kind of how i look at they beat
the colts but they've lost the ravens
they lost the steelers they lost to the
raiders
you know and and i guess that's where
i'm just go i i don't know how good they
are like with you
buffalo and cleveland are both eight and
three how do you view those teams in
your mind i mean i i like cleveland but
i don't think they're as good as buffalo
i don't know i look at their eight and
three in my own mind and think it's just
a little bit better than cleveland are
you the same way or you feel different
what's the signature win for the
cleveland browns what's the one that
stands out the colts is the only one
yeah to me and that was before like you
beat the cults now it's more impressive
than if you beat the cults back in
october right um but but but they just
they they they just are kind of
you know they're very methodical
they're very meat and potatoes
i
i wonder is baker mayfield the long-term
answer am i allowed to say that
i know
is it is that is that is he the
long-term answer no chris or is he
holding baker mayfield oh sorry is he
holding back the browns offense no i i
can't say that he's holding it back i
can't i can't say that listen we got to
be realistic about baker bayfield he's
doing good things they're eight and
three this offense is not about
you know throwing the football for 400
yards all over the field in fact
sometimes it's harder to play
quarterback in these type of offenses
run the ball run the ball run the ball
oh hey we didn't run the ball that well
it's third and nine now make a throw you
know there's never you know we've talked
about this you don't get in a rhythm
sometimes as a quarterback it's not easy
to play that way and let's not forget
for baker mayfield it's
three offensive coordinators you know in
a very short period of time he's had to
learn a lot and deal with a lot of
different ideas and stuff like that so
uh i think you got to be happy about
what baker's doing he's making enough
plays and the big thing is he's not
making any bad mistakes and i think
that's impressive their defense is kind
of a work in progress but man it's the
browns they're eight and three
i mean
we
looking like we should have a parade in
cleveland no matter what after the year
it does i mean one loss or one game in
the playoffs whatever for the state of
this franchise and where they've been to
be where they are right now is awesome i
love to see it it's good for football uh
but you're right yeah i guess what i'm
saying is i think the bills are a better
8-3 team than the the browns right now
browns were 4 and 44 from 2015 through
2017 8-3 this year a huge turnaround and
last year the expectations were sky high
unjustifiably the team did a poor job of
reeling them in this year the bar
naturally is lower because last year
they failed to clear the bar and it has
set the stage for cleveland to have a
special season it looks like it's going
to result in a playoff berth rodney
harrison has been very reluctant to get
on board with that i think he's come
around now and uh and we'll see the next
two weeks look it's either gonna be
eight and five
maybe ten and three
maybe nine and four they gotta win one
of these next two games though to make
people truly believe that not only can
they get to the playoffs but they won't
just get blown off the field by a
superior team in the wild card round
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports